[Musique]
bonsoir première édition du 7 8
politique pour cette saison heureux de
vous retrouver en cette rentrée sur tv
78 3 6 et le sommaire en images maire de
montigny le bretonneux président de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines conseiller départemental michel
laugier va-t-il rejoindre prochainement
le sénat à présent sur la liste des
républicains défendu par gérard larcher
s ses chances sont réelles quelles sont
ses ambitions et quelles seraient les
conséquences d'une victoire nous lui
poserons la question au plateau à dans
quelques instants
et puis en seconde partie à des missions
nous verrons ce que pensent les jeunes
militants de la république en marche des
premiers mois des manuels macron arthur
kenigsberg adhérents des jeunes avec
mâcon dans les yvelines est lui aussi
l'invité et du 7-8 politique la moitié
du sénat va être renouvelée le dimanche
24 septembre 170 postes sont à prendre
lors d'une élection au suffrage
universel indirect par un collège
d'environ 75 mille grands électeurs la
population n'est donc pas appelés aux
urnes mais les députés conseillers
départementaux régionaux ou encore
municipaux bonsoir michel laugier soit
vous figurer sur la liste car c'est un
scrutin de liste et du républicain
gérard larcher pourquoi cette
candidature c'est une première et c'est
une première parce que tout simplement
gérard larcher me l'a proposé dans ce dg
de bonne chose ça veut dire aujourd'hui
que l'agglomération de 50 ha et michel
de juillet représente quelque chose de
tout à fait important dans le
département des yvelines et en plus ce
n'est pas une liste républicain s'est
uni ce qui est ouverte même si gérard
larcher bien sûr sophie primas et
d'autres bien sûr sont membres derby cas
moi je ne suis pas m'en dire des
bouquins et au contraire j'arrive elle
avec une touche son triste sur cette
liste qui aussi avec des personnes qui
ne sont pas inscrits
voilà danse et unis ce très ouverte on
regrette maire président de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines conseiller
départemental ce mandat de sénateur
c'est une évolution logique agir
différemment par la suite y en a qui on
rêve et qui n'ont pas la possibilité de
le faire moi c'est pas encore fait mais
il ya peut-être des chances que ça se
concrétise donc je pense
qu'effectivement le sco n'a pas ce que
c'est investi dans la politique
locale en autant d'années comme je lé
fais ya deux ans tombe bien des il ya
des trains qui passent voilà et quand
ils sont arrêtés en gare il faut pas les
louper on va y venir tout de suite nous
mêmes parce que en cas de victoire vous
devriez quitter votre mandat vous y
pensez vous avez déjà des quelques
quelques regrets peut-être savez des
regrets c'est après qu'il faut les avoir
donc moi je le fais de manière ce raid
en sachant que pour le moment je ne fais
aucune projection parce que c'est une
élection l'élection d'un pas encore eu
lieu c'est le 24 septembre et je figure
en cinquième place sur une liste certes
qui va peser très fort mais aujourd'hui
je ne suis pas sûr d'être élu
donc je ne tire jamais de plan sur la
comète on aura le temps après savez
aujourd'hui j'aime beaucoup ma ville de
manzini je suis profondément ancrée au
coeur de l'agglomération de saint
quentin et bien pour le moment je suis
déjà largement satisfaits et donc si une
autre opportunité se présente
effectivement j'y penserai mais une fois
que l'élection se sera déroulée la
succession vous n'avez pas pensé que ce
soit en mairie que ce soit à
l'agglomération on imagine mal que le
lendemain d'une éventuelle victoire ou
disiez il va falloir que je pense à à
voir comment ça va se passer par la
suite que j'y ai réfléchi c'est une
chose mais que je commence déjà à faire
un partage sur l'héritage de michel ange
alors qu'il a pas encore été élu jamais
je ne ferais vous êtes 5e sur cette
liste vous l'avez préciser je précise
que sur le mandat sortant les
républicains occuper quatre des six
postes dans le département aujourd'hui
vos chansons plutôt réelle d'autant que
le parti présidentiel c'est plutôt
effondré en tout cas dans l'opinion et
d'après les premiers sondages pendant
l'été vous imaginer une telle
configuration
écoutez du jeu si on se place et il ya
des choses ont changé entre avant les
vacances pendant les vacances
oui mais même
ont changé entre l'année dernière était
cette année l'année dernière je pense
que rappeler que le collège électoral du
sénat etc a même composé des élus locaux
les représentants des communes et c'est
vrai que l issue des élections
municipales au départemental régional
bon ça penche vraiment très très à
droite dans le département des yvelines
donc ce qui est venu un peu mettre
quelques interrogations
c'est effectivement le scrutin
présidentiel présidentielle pardon et le
scrutin législatif
voilà donc aujourd'hui c'est vrai que au
bout de quelques semaines on s'aperçoit
qu'il ya quand même
véritable essoufflement dans la spirale
infernale de macron donc c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on fait figure de liste
qui ce qui sera sûrement celle haïssent
le favori bien sûr mais j'adore aussi
beaucoup d'autres
donc il ya des incertitudes parce que je
vous rappelle aussi que c'est un scrutin
à la plus forte moyenne donc on verra le
dire des sièges comment il sera attribué
moi je suis une petite aparté justement
sur les premières mesures les décisions
qui ont été prises on est à plus de 100
jours de la présidence d' emmanuel
macron en tant que président de
l'agglomération et maire également être
d'une commune importante quel regard
vous portez sur les mesures qui ont été
prises et annoncées alors sur les
mesures économiques
moi je pense que ça va plutôt dans le
bon sens par contre dès qu'il s'agit de
toucher ou collectivités territoriales
la ctu de catastrophes regarder pendant
les vacances c'est la taxe d'habitation
alors c'est vrai que ça peut faire rêver
d'exonérer 80 % de personnes tant qu'il
faudra trouver l'argent sauf que comme
il ya une compensation dans un premier
temps il faut trouver 9 milliards 3 et
donc forcément on va le prendre à coeur
dont ce sont toujours les mêmes à
personne et qui vont payer
donc ça veut dire que ont fait rêver et
je reprendrai une expression du
président de république pour moi c'est
de la poudre de perlimpinpin
et puis on va aussi
continuer à faire peser sur les
collectivités locales le désendettement
de la france
on a déjà été prélevé de plus de 11
milliards
cette fois nous annonce 13 milliards et
je vous dis pas alors là c'est
uniquement bien sûr sur la dgf la
dotation globale de fonctionnement qui
diminue aujourd'hui il ya même des
communes dans les épines de que j'ai
rencontré où ils ont aujourd'hui il doit
s'y est eux qui doivent payer l'état on
en on vient dans des situations qui sont
aberrantes et en plus vous avez aussi
les fonds de péréquation
parce que je vous rappelle aussi que on
vient prendre dans les caisses des '
pour doter dans les caisses des autres
et bien là là aussi veut dire c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui on est en train de
pénaliser les communes qui font des
efforts dans la maîtrise de leur budget
qui font des efforts sur tout aussi dans
la maîtrise de leur imposition
les taux ça veut dire que mon client
bretonneux 50 ans et blessant par
exemple victimes de ces mesures
oui tout à fait nous sommes victimes
parce que nous avons des dotations de
l'état qui fondent comme neige au soleil
eo2 prélève toujours plus haut niveau
des péréquations c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un système qui est
capitaine fou ikki fois qu'il faut
inverser les communes qui dépense sans
compter qu'ils augmentent leurs impôts
ils sont mieux aider que les communes
qui font des efforts
c'est pas normal c'est pas logique et
donc il faut que l'on trouve de
nouvelles mesures là dessus on va
revenir aux sénatoriales j'aimerais
avoir votre sentiment sur les
différentes listes qui se présentent
notamment car à droite il ya deux listes
dissidentes celle du maire de maisons
laffitte jacques myard aussi celle d'un
élu de poissy et puis je pourrais
ajouter la liste du modem avec quelques
élus des listes centristes faire
l'unanimité ça a été impossible sur les
limites et vous savez quand vous faites
une liste ya toujours des personnes qui
auraient aimé figurer sur la liste dont
on entend des mécontents dans son temps
l'exprimer autrement replica d'acquis
veulent exister il ya peut être aussi
des formations politiques qui veulent
faire des voix parce que ça peut aussi
rapporter quelques deniers pour la
formation politique
donc moi aujourd'hui j'ai fait le choix
d'être sur la liste de gérard larcher
liste aussi qui est investi par l'ue dei
nationale voilà donc aujourd'hui moi je
pense qu'il ya une légitimité qui est
très très forte sur cette liste là après
sur les autres c'est le choix de chacun
sauf que pour faire un siège peut-être
pour faire le dernier siège la veille à
2919 grands électeurs dans le
département des yvelines
c'est vrai qu'il faut faire 4 186 voix
pour faire un siège et on sait que le
dernier siège je peux passer un petit
peu en dessous il faut au moins faire
entre 300 et 350 voix si on part avec
une liste qui ne fait pas au moins ce
nombre de voix ce sont des voies qui
sont perdus ce sont des voies qui sont
perdus c'est à dire que vous préparez
c'est sur le torse et menace en jeu que
je les ai écoutés oui et ça a été plutôt
facile puisque ya qu une liste qui
aujourd'hui sur le terrain c'est la
liste de gérard larcher qui d'ailleurs a
commencé il ya bien longtemps
moi je les rejoins donc le 14 juillet
puisque c'est le 14 juillet
officiellement que la liste a été
disons mise en place et donc comme
depuis cette date là moi je les ai
rejoints condamné aujourd'hui à 2 154
communes visitées
le président du sénat et ses colistiers
ont déjà visité deux cent cinquante
quatre communes sur 265
donc je pense que aujourd'hui vu le
temps qui nous reste
vu le temps qui nous reste et bien je
veux dire nous on aura fait toutes les
listes on ne saura les visiter chaque
commune aura été présent dans chaque
commune et je pense qu'il ya aucune
liste qui pourrait en faire autant
même pas trois regards sur gérard
larcher justement figure incontournable
de la politique bien sûr des
républicains et puis du sénat aussi
parce qu'il brigue aussi à la présidence
une nouvelle fois écoutez je crois que
gérard a prouvé que c'était un grand
président du sénat il a promis aussi
qu'il avait rassemblée voilà c'est pas
quelqu'un de secteurs au contraire quand
il a été élu à la présidence du sénat et
même quand il était réélu une deuxième
fois
vous avez bien vu que il a été élu par
des sénateurs de différentes
sensibilités dont c'est un grand
rassembleur
c'est quelqu'un qui écoute et c'est
quelqu'un qui sait faire la part des
choses et donc j'apprends beaucoup de
choses à ses côtés et moi j'essaie aussi
de lui apporter l'expérience qui est la
mienne à travers les différents mandats
et tout ce que j'ai pu faire jusqu'à ce
jour ont parlé tout à l'heure de la
politique du gouvernement votre regard
sur le sénat et si jamais vous êtes
amené à siéger également sur le rôle que
doit avoir le sénat est ce que ça doit
rester cette force d'opposition aussi
l'une des dernières finalement déjà vous
dites forces d'opposition au cours de la
dernière mandature en cours des trois
dernières années sous le gouvernement de
monsieur valls le sénat a voté 71% des
lois donc c'est pas une opposition
systématique contraire je crois que le
sénat avec les sénateurs qui composent
cette belle
assemblée qui sont des représentants
finalement des collectivités et bien a
toujours une vision beaucoup plus
pratique et beaucoup plus évidente des
choses contraires au mans ce qui peut se
passer à l'assemblée
aujourd'hui le sénat aura toujours un
rôle de régulateur de modulateurs mais
un rôle de vraiment de vous de vouloir
faire avancer les choses dans le bon
sens reste aussi que vous l'avez vous
l'avez dit le sénat reste quand même une
assemblée importante puisque dans
l'examen des lois et bien les loi doit
être voté dans les mêmes termes à
l'assemblée et au sénat pour les
réformes constitutionnelles par exemple
le sénat devra forcément est plus que ça
puisque pour les réformes
constitutionnelles
il faut que lee et de majorité des trois
cinquièmes des trois cinquièmes
bien sûr du congrès donc le sénat va
encore peser sur les lois conditionnel
est en tous les cas en ce qui concerne
les lois ordinaires
est ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que toute
loi qui concerne aujourd'hui les
collectivités territoriales est examiné
en première lecture au sénat ce qui est
important puisque c'est après que il
était examinée au sénat que ça par
l'assemblée et l'assemblée devra
examiner le texte tel qui sort du cdh a
envoyé que le cdh a toute son importance
dans son rôle de régulateur du pouvoir
législatif quelques questions et à
l'actualité pour terminer cet entretien
l'actualité qui n'est pas uniquement
centré autour du scrutin des
sénatoriales de la fin du mois de
septembre la fusion yvelines
hauts-de-seine
sachant que vous êtes aussi conseiller
départemental elle le ministre de
l'intérieur a jugé le projet juste avant
le début des vacances trop défensif
contraire à l'intérêt général
est-ce qu'il a raison alors écoutez
toute façon c'était aussi une façon de
faire comprendre qu'il peut pas y avoir
une région à deux vitesses on peut pas
voir une métropole où qu'ils soient que
sur paris et la première couronne et que
la deuxième couronne n'existe plus c'est
impossible
tous les cas la vision que nous avons
aujourd'hui delà de la métropole c'est
que la région ile-de-france soit la
région métropole tout simplement
donc voila c'était plutôt pour faire
comprendre ça vraiment aux pouvoirs
publics au président de la république au
gouvernement dont c'est comme ça que
nous sommes allés avec pierre bédier
dans cette démarche là donc c'est bien
pour l'avenir l'avenir vraiment de la
région ile-de-france et la halle à venir
de cette métropole de paris même si ça
ne se fait pas ça a permis de peser au
sein de cette métropole je pense que ça
peut se passe dans le débat parce qu'on
voit bien qu'il ya des départements qui
peuvent s'unir et donc je pense que là
dessus c'est vraiment quelque chose de
très important qui met un alerte le
gouvernement et le président de la
république
et puis dernière question concernant à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines quelles
priorités pour cette année en cette
rentrée avait coûté déjà toujours les
mêmes nos priorités et toujours les
mêmes priorités
on va dire que il ya l'actualité et
l'actualité est bien la première date
importante
c'est le 13 septembre avec la danse
officiel d'invalidation en quelque sorte
les sondages officiels de pour le moment
il ya des accords qui ont été pris mais
il faut qu'on attende la date officielle
et donc je crois que la première date
qui arrive c'est le 13 septembre
et là je veux dire c'est que je de très
important et puis après dans les
semaines qui vont venir
on aura aussi le projet de territoire et
qui sera dévoilé voilà qui sera notre
feuille de route pour les années à venir
et puis après il ya toujours le combat
que nous menons pour attire toujours de
nouvelles entreprises pour faire en
sorte que les choses se passent bien et
puis surtout c'est puisque nous avons
voté les intérêts communautaires avec
les douze communes a bien c'est à partir
du 1er janvier 2018 la véritable
expression de la nouvelle configuration
de 50 ans divine avec vrai budget à 12
avec de vraies compétences à 12 dont
vous voyez un as des mois qu'ils sont
très très chargé et un avenir toujours
eux aussi pour nous important si si le
gouvernement ne vient pas encore
contrarié nos plans avec des mesures
fiscales qui serait trop dur à gérer
merci michel laugier candidat à
l'élection sénatoriale aux côtés de
gérard larcher
dans un instant il sera question
justement de ses premiers mois de
présidence d' emmanuel macron une sous
l'oeil d'un jeune militant a cette fois
ci nous revenons pour l'instant encore
quelques instants sur l'élection
sénatoriale du 24 septembre avec l
annonce des candidats du parti
présidentiel justement présentation à
versailles avec michael et demi d'euros
la république en marche en ordre de
bataille dans les yvelines le mouvement
présenté ce mercredi 6 septembre vers
celle-ci troupes pour les élections
sénatoriales
martin lévriers 54 ans conseiller
municipal versailles et depuis 2008 et
secrétaire général dans un lycée
polyvalent conduira la liste
donc je compte apporter ma pierre très
fortement au sénat sur la partie
professionnelle que je maîtrise et bien
évidemment sur mon accroche mon approche
de terrain politique auprès des
collectivités territoriales la
candidature de berthen ivry et ventre
très clairement dans la volonté que nous
avons dans un certain nombre de
départements d'offrir aux grands
électeurs le choix de pouvoir avoir un
pari du renouveau de la jeunesse de la
thématique de la formation d'éducation
du crédit de quelqu'un qui est dans sa
profession a su montrer les réalisations
extrêmement positive
l'homme politique sera accompagné de
sept autres personnes dont michel dupart
issus du modem conseiller municipal à
poissy et à une grignon maire sans
étiquette de lévis saint nom la femme
politique était la suppléante de jean
noël barrot lors de sa victoire aux
législatives en juin dernier dans la 2e
circonscription des yvelines
j'ai toujours trouvé très intéressant de
travailler avec des bonnes volontés des
gens compétents des gens
disponible et je trouve que le débat
démocratique s'exerce de manière tout à
fait formidable
lorsque nous travaillons avec une
diversité de sensibilité après avoir
raflé onze circonscriptions sur 12 lors
des élections législatives dans le
département la république en marche n'a
pour l'instant pas annoncé d'objectifs
chiffrés pour les sénatoriales second
invité de 7,8 politique de rentrée
arthur arthur kenigsberg pardon
responsable du pôle formation des jeunes
avec matheron dans le département des
yvelines bonsoir il était question de
ces élections sénatoriales on sent que
la formation du président n'a pas
forcément une ambition démesurée sur ce
scrutin
non je pense que votre jugement est faux
maintenant c'est vrai qu'on est assez
réaliste on sent que les collectivités
territoriales ne sont pas très
satisfaite des mesures annoncées par le
gouvernement
maintenant j'aimerais aussi leur
rappeler que dans les yvelines par
exemple la plupart ont soutenu le
programme de françois fillon soutenu par
le candidat tête de liste gérard larcher
et le programme de françois fillon
prévoyait des mesures encore plus
drastiques pour les collectivités
territoriales c'est à dire la
suppression de tous les contrats idée un
rabotage hauteur de 20 milliards d'euros
donc un plan encore plus drastique que
le programme des douars filet on sent
tout de même que dans l'opinion la
dynamique emmanuel macron c'est un petit
peu il ya une petite érosion
oui donc vous nous parler des sondages
sauf que emmanuel macron justement par
rapport à ses prédécesseurs ne
gouvernera pas en fonction des sondages
je pense qu'il ira jusqu'au bout des
réformes à mener pour la france les
sondages ne doivent pas dicter la vie
politique du pays
comment se porte la section jeunes avec
macron dans le département des yvelines
est réellement ce mouvement jeunes
comment elle sa porte
il se porte très bien on a recruté
beaucoup de jeunes
cet été on a créé des premières sections
jeunes avec macron lycéens donc
aujourd'hui on a 350 membres inscrits
dans les gènes avec mc ren 78 dont on
sent qu'ils sont véritablement actif
donc la section pour l'instant prépare
aussi ces élections sénatoriales
donc on est au plus près de l'équipe du
candidat martin lévriers donc on l'aide
pour les coups de téléphone aux aux élus
on l'aide à préparer ces rencontres sur
le terrain on est au plus proche de lui
comme on l'a été durant les législatives
comme on l'a été durant les
présidentielles
les jeunes doivent peut-être un atout
majeur pour cette liste quel âge pour
justement ces jeunes avec macron
voilages et la moyenne d'âge dans les
yvelines elle est de 22 ans 22 ans et ce
sont des jeunes qui ne se sont jamais
engagés au poly en politique des
républicains du parti socialiste
d'autres formations
alors il ya beaucoup de sensibilité qui
se retrouve chez les jeunes avec macron
surtout dans le 78 donc on a des anciens
du parti socialiste on a des anciens de
lui dit on a des anciens des
républicains donc toutes les
sensibilités sont à peu près représentés
enfin les sensibilités plutôt modéré
c'est vrai que les jeunes insoumis et
les jeunes frontistes je pense auront du
mal à venir chez les jeunes avec macron
mais peut-être qu'un jour ils
retrouveront raison et nous rejoindront
on n'est pas sectaires on commence à un
mouvement politique par le rassemblement
et non pas par le rejet est donc toutes
sensibilités politiques sont les
bienvenus maintenant c'est clair qu'il
faut être en accord avec la politique du
gouvernement et des manuels macro et
leurs visions et vous êtes en accord
avec c'est justement cette politique du
gouvernement ces mesures qui sont prises
peut-être est sûre la décision de
diminuer les allocations de 2 5 euros
les apl c'est mal vécu aussi par les
plus jeunes
we say say say mal vécu et c'est tout à
fait compréhensible mais il y avait
aussi il y à une pédagogie de la part du
gouvernement d'expliquer que les apl
était aussi un système pervers c'est à
dire qu'en augmentant les appels d'un
euro les loyers augmenté de 78 centimes
en moyenne donc y rester que 22 centimes
dans la poche des étudiants donc sa
nourrice est un système pervers un
système qui n'était plus finançables et
qui ne l'est plus
emmanuel macron ils doivent edouard
philippe doivent assumer aussi un budget
laissé par l'ancienne mandature nous
comprenons parfaitement la colère des
étudiants
mais la mission du gouvernement et du
président de la république c'est de
faire appel à la pédagogie d'expliquer
ces mesures
maintenant nous la comprenons tout à
fait parce que il est vrai que les
étudiants aussi marre de prendre à
chaque fois pour la scolarité coûte cher
on le sait les lions sont souvent aussi
en situation de précarité doivent avoir
un petit boulot à côté ont du mal à se
loger
la vie coûte cher pour un étudiant même
de serviles à la vie enfin de chair et
je suis moi même étudiant donc je peux
je peux vous assurer que c'est cette vie
étudiante et cher maintenant on sait que
notre pays et doit faire des efforts
donc les étudiants doivent également
faire maintenant c'est toute la mission
du gouvernement et et d'emmanuel macron
d'expliquer pourquoi cette mesure mais
c'est vrai qu'on aimerait aussi que
qu'il y ait d'autres
d'autres personnes qui fasse des efforts
c'est à dire que je pense qu'il y a dû
enfin les jeunes vraiment du mal à
comprendre pourquoi on supprime lisf
même si enfin la majorité des jeunes ont
du mal à comprendre pourquoi on supprime
lisf pourquoi on s'attaque pas à
l'évasion fiscale qui coûte 600
milliards d'euros à la france
vous nous dites roi vous adhérez mesures
du gouvernement que vous attendez aussi
vous m'avez tant que militants d'avoir
aussi d'autres si oui on en attend
d'avoir d'autres singh parce qu'on n'est
pas qu'un parti de supporters c'est à
dire que les mesures du gouvernement
d'edouard philippe et du président de la
république emmanuel macron nous les
attendons mais nous restons aussi
critique
c'est à dire que on ne sera pas là peut
dire toutes les réformes si elle nous
déplaisent on saura les signaler les
appels nous les comprenons pas ce que l
on était très bien expliquée par le le
premier ministre mais nous attendons
aussi d'autres mesures fortes
aujourd'hui comment se développe cette
section jana
avec macron justement au regard de ce
que vous nous dites vous dites on n'est
pas une partie d'une section de
supporters
les gens vous continuer d'adhérer les
jeunes continuent d'adhérer sans se
renseigner ils veulent aussi peut-être
plus d'explications et vous parlez du
travail d'accompagnement de pédagogie
que vous faites c'est ça et en plus je
suis donc responsable de la formation
chez les jeunes avec macron donc j'ai
enfin mon travail c'est d'expliquer la
mesure du gouvernement d'expliquer
pourquoi par exemple le gouvernement
décide de baisser de 2,5 euros les les
appels par mois
c'est une mission de 2,2 pédagogie parce
que je pense que les français doivent
aussi comprendre et les plus jeunes
doivent comprendre vers quel vers quelle
vision le président et le gouvernement
entendent maintenant il y avoue vous
parlez d'un souffle qui qui s'amoindrit
dans le service le parlement maintenant
si chez les jeunes ce souffle n'est pas
perceptible on a toujours beaucoup de
jeunes qui viennent
tu vas nous rejoindre et qui sont très
contents de retrouver justement une
nouvelle envie de faire la politique qui
avec de nouvelles méthodes
une dernière question comment vous avez
adhéré pourquoi vous avez adhéré à cette
section jeunes avec macron j'ai adhéré à
ce exception gêne avec macron parce que
j'avais le sentiment qu'on pouvait faire
de la politique autrement
c'est à dire le plus est dans cette
logique des anciens partis c'est à dire
attendre son heure avant d'être de
pouvoir faire véritablement de la
politique là dès le début engagé en
politique déjà rejeté engagé à lui dit
j'étais engagé au parti radical
valoisien aussi et je le suis toujours
au parti radical parce que la double
appartenance et est accepté
mais il ya aussi cette nouvelle envie
donc de soutenir emmanuel macron et un
nouveau projet nouvelle vision pour la
france et de donner aussi tout son
avenir à la jeunesse et à la jeunesse
française qui le méritent merci arthur
kenigsberg responsable du pôle formation
des jeunes avec macron dans le
département des yvelines nous refermons
aussi ce premier set 8 politique rendez
vous le 6 octobre pour une nouvelle
émission avec 2
vos invités et puis bien sûr l'actualité
politique est à suivre au quotidien
assure tv 78 replay est dès à présent
sur notre site internet à bientôt
[Musique]